da habe ich einfach mein eigenes
Meersalz aus Meerwasser hergestellt das
Meerwasser war am Anfang noch ja so
ziemlich sandig und irgendwie dreckig
deswegen habe ich das erstmal durch so
ein feines Tuch gefiltert danach sah das
aber immer noch ziemlich praktisch aus
deswegen habe ich mir so eine
Konstruktion aus kaffeefiltern gebaut
und das insgesamt glaube ich so fünf Mal
gefiltert bis das Wasser richtig schön
klar war und dann habe ich das auf dem
Herd gestellt die Strompreise sind ja
gerade so extrem hoch deswegen habe ich
das direkt nach dem Kochen gemacht als
der hat noch richtig heiß war und dann
ist da einfach schon direkt mein erstes
eigenes Salz entstanden ich war so
unfassbar stolz und froh dass das
einfach wirklich funktioniert und dann
ging es weiter und es wurde immer mehr
schaut euch das mal an mein Herz an
danach war irgendwie aus wie scheiße
aber ich war einfach so so stolz jetzt
müsst wie viele Liter mehr Wasser ich
dafür gebraucht habe und ich lese das in
einem der nächsten Videos auf